hey taste buddies just a special
announcement before we get into this
week's episode uh i apologize for my
appearance
uh i i was up all night um
due to the events of uh
and the reaction i should say
of last episode uh weed versus alcohol
and uh
the reason i was up all night was
because i decided to revisit the episode
based on the comments that were coming
in on youtube that were very very
um adverse let's say there's a nice way
of saying towards what i was saying
and so anyway i rewatched the episode
and
i just can't believe
how
right i was
i mean
i was so right i was awake all night
excited i just i can't sleep i'm it's
like
whoa i'm giddy i'm giddy
i'm just kidding i wasn't up all night i
just uh didn't put myself together when
i woke up before i did this video
because weed enthusiasts i wanted to
appear in a form that you could relate
to you know the guy doesn't get out of
the house doesn't get off his ass
doesn't really comb his hair you know
oh man i gotta reach for the bong man
[Laughter]
god damn for a lot of weed smoke cause
you guys are angry
you know i was angry on the episode but
i'm a drunk
drunk's supposed to be angry
weed smoke is supposed to be chill
you guys are so mad
can't handle your strains bro
can't handle your streams
anyway salami are still friends
enjoy today's episode
pool versus beach
uh it gets a little heated at the end
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t
but
and it's another round from joe and now
here we go sure we should be doing that
chance we can i never feel comfortable
doing it i don't feel comfortable either
but that's kind of where the excitement
is okay you know what i mean yeah but i
hope people know that like we know
we know i don't know if someone's not
tuning in to being like what are these
two adults they're cheerleading they
know that we know okay and we know that
they know okay and we know that they
know that we know that they know i love
it i follow it you follow me uh today's
let's just jump right in topic is it's
not
by the way thanks for staying with us
last week
i mean for the intro to the
non-food-related
battles
that was a serious heater like we had we
just had a straight up fight
by the way shout outs to i forgot to do
this it's already posted the new one
okay i forgot to do this before shout
outs to
uh the folks that sent us the renditions
of sleep sleep my baby yes yes um so
what am i looking for here uh oh the
email check out my instagram or even did
you maybe repost it on tastebuds
instagram jonathan gibbons did the full
orchestra
it was insane it was an orchestral take
and then there was another version i
sent to you and pimp
um that i oh man i don't want to leave
this guy's name out hold on a second
the other one is from jack bertelli you
can follow jacket at jack burtelli which
is spelled b-e-r-t-e-l-l-i
sax s-a-x
uh thank you to both of you guys uh i
really we really appreciate
uh the renditions of the the song and uh
thank you very much i loved it and uh
played it many times yeah now
getting to today's
hopefully this will be a calm i think
this is another polarizing one i think
you're a beach person or you're a pool
person i think it'll be polarizing i i
don't think it'd be quite as heated as
last week the way we phrased this poll
today wasn't which is better because on
any given day either could be better
because like on a beautiful day i might
be like i'm feeling the beach today so
the way we worded it was which do you
prefer
right so like in the long run the long
haul are you a beach person or your pool
person hopefully it's received as such
sure no there's no surprise with me
please straighten out your mic thing i
have an ocd thing going on yeah just
nice and nice and easy just pull that
yeah there it is no when we're in his
house it's his rules
through and through
anything else i could do for you i am
should i straighten the threads on my i
am a pool person
through and through vacation at the
beach love the beach ice challenge
memories at the beach spend love a good
bonfire i love a good sandwich uh
whether i brought to the beach i love i
love the ocean i love water
so for the beach
i mean a tropical crystal clear water
that is a very amenable like 75 degrees
nothing necessarily beats that but
that's not the beach all the time that's
the tropics let's let's talk about the
beach that the rest of us don't like the
sand let's talk about the beach that the
rest of us regular people have to go to
not the fancy famous guy just said
that's not all the time you've never
been to one
no and you want to rub my face in it
you've never been to a tropical beach i
also don't own any gold or diamonds have
you ever i don't have a swedish bank
account i don't know diamonds
i don't have a swedish bank you've never
been to the tropical beach no
joe you're lying
i'm not lying lie down
listen oh wait i did the jokers was the
joker's cruise beach was that a tropical
beach no the cruise that went through
the downtown harbors here the cruise i
don't know where we were you don't think
you went to the tropics on the cruise
the beach we went to on that cruise oh
you mean on the cruise was that true oh
yeah we went to when we went to the suez
canal or the hudson river of course it
was a tropical beach i didn't know
that's the one time i went to traffic
you know that you went for five days you
were on a ship going through the tropics
listen if you think i knew where i was
for those five days
i was playing craps and drinking until 3
a.m every night okay you know i barely
got through my shows the point is this
the point is this it was a great time it
was it was fun it was a lot
sorry are you telling me that in your
life outside of the one cruise you did
with us you have never gone to jamaica
mexico
uh
british virgin islands
turks and caicos no
aruba no
bermuda no bahamas no key lago gelago
montego isn't that where trump is no i
don't know
wait what why what why in the world have
you just gone to a beach for a small
vacation evening
i'm sorry that i'm such a peasant
that i haven't gone to that's true it's
very affordable even i have been
uh yeah were you just there
pimp i see what we pay you of course
you've been
yeah
i don't mean like oh never not i mean
never go no no i'm being funny
uh oh you know what i went to um
uh uh what's that place in mexico i went
to uh
saint where sammy hagar's town in mexico
that he created cabo san lucas oh yeah
yeah that's a big issue he's the mayor
there or something like that or whatever
it's the name of the town the name of
his tequila
yeah i went i went to the beach there is
that considered tropical
it's it's isn't the mexi yeah of course
it's mexico
is mexico tropical on the on the on the
ocean side maybe not the gulf side is
that i don't know which side that is oh
if you went to cabo no cabo is out west
that there's two cabos oh okay i don't
know which is sammy i just assume that
i'm sorry but i just assumed that in in
your life you are a learned and
experienced person
a middle-aged person
you you i i'm just surprised you have
never been like oh let me go somewhere
for a weekend and spend
a thousand dollars to do it i'm not a
big uh i'm not a huge uh vacation guy i
never have been so you're arguing for
beach
based on local beach oh yeah wow you
must love the beach the beach is great
you must love it
i'll tell you primarily i'm arguing with
you you're going to argue pools on the
hole
i mean i can't deliver it and we had
we had a pool growing up i had a pool we
had a pool my grandfather bought us a
pool before he died okay we had a pool
in ground
uh okay i grew up with a pool pools are
great but and i'm basing this primarily
on jersey shore and myrtle beach which
is where we went as a kid
there's nothing like sand into that
ocean i got the chills why because i
can't believe you're going to base your
battle of pool versus beach just on
myrtle and the germans threw a mob talk
in there too
okay
yeah i've been to montauk you know
oh
uh this is very interesting you know why
i didn't grow up with the pool i longed
for a pool i wished i had a pool i had a
community pool in the apartment complex
i lived in which when i was very young
which i was in but it closed at certain
hours it was only open during the summer
and i was in that thing
every minute that it was open every
summer for like 10 years but like it was
always taken away from me and then after
i moved from there i could only be
invited to a pool and then also too
that's not good that's not good either
because you were the weird kid in the
pool all the time there were couples
that wanted to go down and have like a
glass of wine in the pool and they were
like the kid the french we grew up with
a lot of volcano kids in the freaking
pool kids really took over the pool
there was a lot of kids in the thing but
but my point being though like no but my
point being is that like uh you know
there's nothing worse
like
when
it's a beautiful gorgeous summer day you
don't have plans and it's hot out and
you wish you could go in a pool and you
either i mean you i guess you can go to
a public pool i never did that but like
you wish someone would invite you in
their pool a beach is like i guess i
guess you could say that with a public
pool i was going to make the point that
a beach is 24 7 365 whenever you want it
as long as you're near the coast
you know i mean in my experience we live
in new york i'm near the coast but also
too you can't jump in the ocean you know
24 7.
but for me like we the beach was
at our
will
and the pool necessarily wasn't i'm not
sure that if that's where it comes into
play because believe me i love nothing
more than some light waves and just
floating up and down i do have a fear
every single time i'm in the ocean even
if it's clear waters that even
a regular fish is going to get a little
too close
maybe get up my shorts my shorts or
something or i'm gonna step on a crab
it's gonna bite my toe or god forbid a
shark and then recently i read an
article of this guy that took a drone
out over the ocean for long periods of
time and every time he did it he saw a
shark in the water that was always
within a couple of hundred feet of
people and he used it to say that sharks
are around so much more than we have any
right to believe and that just goes to
prove to you how much sharks shouldn't
be feared and how they don't attack you
that much there's like x amount of shark
attacks a year but if you knew how many
sharks were next to you at all times
without attacking you like that's
supposed to go as far as to say we're
more scared of them than they are of us
what do you think are they more scared
of us than the damn it i screwed it up
damn it that's what the point the point
he was making is and that's always in
the recesses of my mind even when i'm in
the possible ocean situation i'll say
this i'll say this by the way if you
didn't notice folks we are already into
the
b-a-t-t-l-e buds
we jumped right in this week the chance
would have been too close the chance
would have been too close together okay
uh
here's what i love about the beach it's
an event i mean a pool is great i we've
we've hung out at many pools together
i once recently saw you stay in a pool
for i'm not exaggerating i think nine
hours
literally without leaving
except twice to pee which was brought
into discussion at one point because sal
hasn't left the pool enough
for the amount of time she should i
don't pay a lot i have a whole bid on it
okay i pee every two days for seven
minutes so
you were in the i've never seen anybody
stay in water for that long in my life
you ate
two full meals in that pool nothing
better than eating the meal poolside uh
i don't love it because your hands are
wet and you have to dry them you know
but
but i will say this for me the beach
i love a pool
the beach and the pool's got a lot of
amenities at the beaches and have you
got diving boards and things and rafts
and things like that but i love the
beach the beach is an event you go it's
a destination you get there you gotta
find the perfect spot you set up shop
you got a cooler full of beers or or
juices or sodas or whatever the hell it
is you bring maybe you bring a picnic
basket maybe you don't and you do that
great we're gonna get up and walk up to
that weird little booth up there that
sells hot dogs and cheeseburgers then
the guy comes by with the ice cream pops
all right maybe you go flirt with the
lifeguard and you have a summer romance
you know what i mean yeah it's just
the beach to me is amazing you really
took that to somewhere
and i get it
the beach is romanticized as it should
be and even you got things like baywatch
and
i get it i get the beach i get fun in
the sun i get all that stuff
uh
what is this a new study which assessed
the health of more than 27 000
beachgoers over four years found
individuals who played in the sand at a
greater risk of diarrhea and
gastrointestinal illness than those who
stuck
to their towels i'm telling you about
the sand now let me take you what is
this wait a second what is this study
from there's no header
it's from newser.com
i mean come on
but let me take you through my local
beach experience okay because sure
there's elevated beaches okay but our
local the one that i
had access to the most the one that i've
experienced with the most what was my
life and still is my life experience
with the beach when i'm not
going on a vacation and paying money to
go there
i get all the things you said all the
pluses i get all the nostalgia and the
the routine of finding the spot and
getting the towel and you know putting
it on and taking a dip and making a sand
cast and going back and all those things
are true and bring a cooler and having a
sandwich and all they're all cool
they're all cool but there's also all
these other elements these in these
these variables with the beach that i
don't feel i have with a pool and i
could start from getting there fighting
the traffic to get there finding parking
being three blocks from the beach
carrying the cooler your your towels the
bag the beach chair lugging it over
there you're in flip-flops you get up to
the freaking boardwalk splinter you get
down on the sand you take off your
things it's
lava hot you're already sweating you're
traipsing through all these people some
people are playing their radio loud some
people are throwing a football around
some people are loud and obnoxious
you're going this it's so packed that
you find the six foot area that you can
lay your own town there's someone to
left someone to your right someone in
front of you someone behind you you sit
down it's scorching hot the sand feels
like sandpaper it's getting in you it's
in your crack it's in your balls it's in
your toes all right your feet in the
sand feels nice whatever i'm dying now
i'm gonna go into the water the water's
too rough
there's jellyfish today there's too much
seaweed the water's too cold there's too
many rocks in the water there's too many
people in the water you're naming all
worst-case scenarios but i'm saying that
anyone but any one of those things any
one of them you can pluck them out and
they're pretty it's a pretty high chance
one of those is going to be there on one
of them all right but i would say this
to that i would say this to all that
first of all pimp just put on relaxing
white noise video of beach and the waves
crashing there is no pool white noise
machine
nothing is as relaxing as the beach in
my opinion when it comes to nature
okay very good very strong point and i
would say this too i would say this too
anything worth its weight in salt
water
it's a beach joke
anything worth its weight in salt
i'm glad you enjoyed that i'm laughing
at how bad it was i know that was
supposed to be bad i know
anything worth its weight in salt takes
a little effort of course in a perfect
world we could all have a nice pool
three feet from our back door that we
could just traipse down to and swim in
at our own convenience and we could have
full control over the elements i mean we
can yeah but yeah and we could turn the
heat to what we want it to be and
but when you have to get up and go and
achieve and obtain the thing it's more
it's more special you could spend 31
days straight in a pool and i promise
you you will have less memories
significant memories than if you went to
the beach five days that month that
because you were going to remember the
journey you were going to remember what
it took to get there and everything else
not to mention
chemicals in the pool water not clean
you know there's a reason why a
saltwater pool is a big perk and it's
more expensive because the chemicals you
got to put in most pool water uh
although they kill bacteria microbes uh
they can also have very negative effects
in the natural environment it reacts
quickly to other i'm trying to read this
like i made it up
i swear to god you're reading it like we
read the ads you're reading it like i'm
looking at you i'm like why is he why is
he making this conversational just read
the thing
it was so funny i was enjoying i was i
was getting to a peak enjoyment and so
you called it
you slipped into a hello fresh right
there yeah yeah yeah
um but you know what i'm saying it's
like it's like of cour look
you can make the argument that's that's
a pretty decent point about you go five
days to the beach you'll have more
memories in 30 days in the pool maybe i
like that a pool is there for you when
you need it like
you said you get a bigger reward for
doing the whole journey that it takes to
get to the beach but like what about the
fact that the pool is the opposite of
that and the pool is there easy simple
when you need it it's reliable it does
the job
okay it can be as relaxing
should i be looking
wucha says pool yuck what we'll call it
human soup
well you know what very funny that is
really funny like public pool
it is true but how is the beach not
human soup then but here's my point
here's my point
the beach is soup forget about it you
know what's in the ocean water somebody
just wrote sandy gooch which is a very
funny term but here's the thing here's
the thing too
you could argue
you could argue and sandy gooch is a
great name for a character it is yeah
you could argue this
you could argue that a hot tub
is superior to a pool
why you could say well
my hot tub is in my basement and we've
got a hot tub room down there and we
never have to worry about the cool air
and we never have to worry about the
water being cold and you never have to
heat it up to a certain degree because
the hot tub is always a hot tub blah
blah blah and we go down to a private
room and god damn me and my wife can
have sex in that thing and nobody can
see us
my point is is
these amenities
these privileges if you will
that get that get that get piled on to
something like a pool which is really a
luxury it's a luxury item it's not
nobody's going to
nobody
and i will say it with confidence
nobody is going to argue a public pool
over a public beach
nobody
nobody's jumping but that truly is not
even
let's not even go there why not that's
because that's not but that's a lot of
people's summer is the public pool if
they had a choice from that public pool
packed with kids and people okay and and
and uh beach beach chair whatever those
recliners whatever those things are
called chair on top of chair on top of
chair on top of chair people's water is
splashing in the face between that and
having to go through the extra effort to
carve out your own little slice of
heaven on a beach they're picking beach
every time now if we want to talk about
a look you could argue private pool all
you want and i'm with you i could argue
private beach i was at my buddies but
now you're talking about what are we
talking about private beaches but if
you're going to do that i mean the best
beach in the world versus the best pool
in the world is let me just get it i'll
throw the beach but i mean i'll throw
those general terms here i'll throw this
out accessible terms i'll throw this at
you sure accessible to well
your own pool is not that accessible to
a lot of people that's a pretty okay but
a lot of people have above grounds
that's why above ground is profiling
that's right in your yard it's giving
you what you need right and a lot of
people do have pools and a lot of people
have friends of family that have pools
so
the privacy is still going to ring as a
positive
people when talking about the pool let
me throw this at you you go to i was
just at my buddy's house up in uh city
island
okay up in the bronx
back of the house has a little sliver of
beach it's his
he owns 300 yards or 300 feet or
whatever it is of the ocean that's part
of his property
you bought you go to buy a house and
they tell you here's one with an
in-ground pool whatever or here's one
with [ __ ] but this is such a it's like
you're talking about hitting the lottery
but it's not i don't know argue on the
on
on this on this extreme case i'm just
saying but we're talking about it in
basic sense if somebody said to you for
the rest of your life you could have
your own little slice of tiny beast or
your own i don't even think that gonna
be applied to one argument why not
because it's not accessible but it but
i'm sending one and i'm saying
i love a pool if you tell me do i want
my own private beach or a private place
i'm talking about a sliver of beach
that's smaller than a pool that meets a
bay let's say okay you could talk about
a lake house with some sand that leads
up to a lake what would you take what
would you take a heated in-ground pool
or a beach out or a lake house with some
sand no way i i i'm not swimming in that
lake i'm not going to snapping turtles
and it's a slimy floor
and the minnows in there i don't like
swimming in lakes i don't like it the
ocean is big enough where people can
fish and [ __ ] could scram a lake they're
not going anywhere it's like you're
locked a lake is like you're locked in a
room with the fish
i don't want to be locked in a room with
the fish at some point or another you're
going to cross paths there's nowhere for
them to go they can scram all they want
they're going to loop back around and
find their way to my nuts and i don't
want it here's an article la beach
closes after 17 million gallons of
untreated sewage discharge into the
discharge into the bay by by the way
what a surprise la did something wrong
yeah
a nice saltwater heated pool floating on
a swan raft oil spills i'm not afraid of
a pelican coming to me on its last gas
you're worried about what that was
doing i'm not afraid of it you're
worried about that girl coming up to me
with a bending
because you need to be
you need to be you're worried about
what's that bad for you yes yes glorious
i mean we've all been exposed to
chlorine for our whole lives google how
bad is chlorine for you
uh yeah chlorine's not great for you man
as mentioned above one of the primary
side effects of chlorine exposure is
that it causes dryness and irritation
when paired with hair treatments and
dyes hair can become extremely all right
it's not that bad for you it's not
that's what i'm saying why would why
would chlorine be the go-to thing for
pools for a hundred years do better next
time when you google something
look man all right all right
you
you're telling me it takes more effort
to go to the beach and so there's more
reward
okay so you take a big swing and you
have a bit of a payoff i'm listed all
the negative things that are very common
on any beach visit that i could do
without i hate sitting also by the way
if the water's too rough or that rip
tides that you're gonna [ __ ] die in
or the current if the current's too
strong and the lifeguards take everybody
out if the water's too cold well you you
just can't handle it if it's too rocky
where you're gonna slice your leg open
if it's jellyfish season if it's you
know if it's like saying that if a kid
it's one of those things it's like a 50
50 shot every time the worst feeling in
the world is getting to the beach
it's hot out and you can't go in the
water for a relief it's too strong it's
too cold it's too rocky it's happened to
me in my 44 years on this planet
maybe two times it's happened to me
an abundance of time so much so that i
feel i have ptsd every time i go to the
beach that one of those things is going
to come true all i'm saying is it's a
controlled private environment that is
accessible to you all the time but
you're you're talking about but hold on
a second you're talking you want a whole
body rub once a month or a foot rub
every day
full body rub once a month not me not i
french fry but i'm doing a foot rub
every second
in all fairness i had to figure out
which was an equivalent to support my
argument and i picked it it took me a
second
uh every day versus once in a while i
don't know that i want a foot rub to be
honest my feet are ticklish i don't know
my point is this point you're talking
about though you're talking about
accessibility and what people can get to
easily and on the average person the
average person does not have access to a
private pool they just don't it was that
was a big deal when i was growing up and
our house got our pool when we got our
pool it was the talk of the suburb of
the of the of the berg because only
one other house in the entire suburb had
a three at an in-ground pool and the
other house in the pool was above ground
but it was a big deal but i don't
understand how that applies to this
argument because you're asking our
listeners is which do you because it
stands to reason that most people have
had a beach experience even if it was
one and a pool experience even because
because you're because all the negative
things you're saying about the beach i
could apply to a public pool and you're
saying that's not a fair comparison it
is you have to compare that you have to
take into account that at a public pool
it's disgustingly crowded okay you're on
top of one another it's it's packed but
i feel like there's no swimming there is
no relaxing it's kids in the pool
playing games and you're getting hit in
the head with balls and stuff like that
these are all things that are happening
kids are peeing in the pool so if you
want to bring out all the worst aspects
of a beach experience okay i'm going to
bring up all the worst aspects of a
public policy fair but but
but
i'm thinking that most people are going
to be answering this that either have a
pool their family has a pool their
neighbor has a pool and they have had
pool accidents that's throughout their
life enough to be able to talk to
conform an opinion on which i like talk
to any talk to any city talk to any city
kid they do not know somebody when i got
to the bathroom you said i got out twice
to go you think i want to go in my own
house or my friend's house and pee there
god forbid i got to do more than pee
what happens at the beach when you got
to pee pee in the ocean oh god and what
happens when you got to go elsewhere you
got to go what about that public
restroom oh my god you know what that is
i picture
your bathroom at the gates of hell
that's what that's what the gate is
going to walk through a beach bathroom
how often are you needing to do a two
with this i don't know but i'm just
saying probably never i've never done it
and i never will i've never had to do it
holding something like that until i have
to get rushed i had to do that let's
talk about another amenities people [ __ ]
no you don't think people [ __ ] in the
ocean because they do because they do
okay
well i mean but what are the chances
you're encountering that [ __ ] it's a
gigantic body of water that spans half
of the globe what are you talking about
i'm just saying i'm just saying and no i
don't think people [ __ ] me i love the
fact that when i if i need to use the
restroom and i'm having a pool day no
big deal i'm in the comforts of wherever
i am but you're talking the beast is
like [ __ ] i gotta pee you are talking i
got a piece i mean you're gonna walk
down there talking i'm shameful
and just stare at people like you're a
two-year-old child so if you're if
you're only going to put into con i
don't want to venture to the public if
you're only going to then i get to talk
about private beaches because you're
only talking about the private pool
experience and i'm sorry i hate to break
it to you most people do not have access
to that that is not a common thing at
all you talk to city kids they go to a
public pool okay even a lot of kids in
the suburbs it's expensive kids love
that it's you're talking about an adult
that doesn't love a public pool the kids
can't get enough of it okay so what if
you're in a public pool then you got to
go to the public pool bathroom it's
disgusting it's just as disgusting as
that beach public bathroom okay but i'm
really thinking that most people are
going to interpret this with the way
they grew up i didn't say they had to
have a pool buddy i just said that they
had a family member a neighbor or a
friend that had
if we're talking about the way most
people grew up i don't know one person
in my life immediately besides you
that would pick a pool over a beach
experience
don't have a pool i never had a pool my
entire life to this day i don't have a
pool i'm aware i choose pool i have been
in a pool
a thousand times i don't have one so i'm
giving you
you're telling me that this experience
doesn't exist you tell me everyone's
experience is a public pool i'm not
telling you the experience doesn't exist
i'm telling you i've been in above
ground i've been in a friend of a
friend's place i've been in a sure sure
people have opinions people have access
to pools it's not just public pool a
bust i didn't say it was all right but
i'm saying if you're only you're going
to talk about all the perks of the
private pool and none of the detriments
of a public pool then i get to talk
about a private beach then i get to
bring that into the mix it's
so not common it's not that it's how
many okay
how many pools are in the united states
of america of course it's less common
that all right so you know babe and
we're gonna talk about keeps right now
that two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. yeah no it's true my
grandfather
bawled by 14.
wow i mean i don't know if he'd be a
candidate for keemstar because keeps
helps you keep what you have yeah he's
not going to start growing hair back
from a cue ball ahead of 14 now
so he's not going to grow hair back with
keeps for two reasons yeah one he went
full ball by 14 it doesn't grow hair it
keeps what you have to grandfather's
dead keeps offering the name keeps yeah
you keep it yes keeps offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door discreetly every three months
you don't have to leave your home
treatments start at only 10 bucks which
is super affordable they have more
five-star reviews than any of their
competitors and here's the thing
prevention is the key
thing so your treatment can take like
four to six months to see results so act
fast get to preventing today not
tomorrow you want to take action against
hair loss go to keps.com
taste buds you're going to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash taste buds get
that first month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste punch
can i suggest the slogan
keeps
gets to preventing let's talk babble
babe i love to babble with you i love
the babble with my friends i love to
babble and listen to babel on podcast
but babel is putting that word into new
territory because babel our sponsor is
teaching you how to speak other
languages let's talk about what babel is
it's the number one selling uh language
learning app okay they feature bite size
lessons uh 15-minute lessons even yeah
so you can take lessons on the go
there's over 14 languages
and they actually uh teach you in a way
uh that is useful you're not gonna learn
extemporaneous stuff it's conversational
it's stuff from menus it's greetings uh
if you go to another country you can use
the app to you know to speak to people
and even in real time and i love this
you can access uh the lessons and in
addition to the uh lessons you can
access podcasts and games
and videos and stories and even live
classes like you know what this makes me
think of you see things like games and
videos whatever
why does that stop after you're a child
learning should always be enjoyable
presented in an enjoyable way it's going
to help you learn i love that they do it
in a fun way so right now you can get
three months additionally free when you
purchase three months so that's
basically six months for the price of
three right yep you're gonna go to
babel.com and use promo code tastebuds
that's b-a-b-b-e
promo code taste buds babble language
for life
but hold on i'm just i'm just saying
like okay then i'll bring up this don't
bring up this have you ever been to
uh there are 10.4 million residential
this 10.4 million residential pools
united states and three hundred thousand
thousand swimming pools out of how many
people in the united states pimp what's
the total uh number
300 million i think it's
more than that but on the
328 million okay so
out of what is that math christ
sure it's it's that's a low percentage
it's uh it's probably like
three percent three percent yeah i know
but that's that's three percent that own
it
not three percent and that that's not
true but but here's my point people have
a pool how many friends family members
and neighbors you think they let in
their pool
why are we even you always do this right
access to a pool argued the marriage
we've argued the merits but when you say
to me something like you can't take into
account private beach versus private
pool then i'm going to say back to you
then you can't say how many people
doesn't count this is how we do it this
10.4 million private pools
how many people own their own private
beach i didn't say that you can't
compare private pool to private beach i
didn't say that i said you're talking
about the amenities that a lot of people
don't have access to you're talking
about the luxury i think you want to
bring in private beaches okay 80 people
then i'll do you one better then i'll do
you one better okay let's talk about
private pools guess what most people's
private pools aren't heated okay and
that water is ice cold no it's not yes
it is once you're a week into the summer
that thing maintains itself so i grew up
with one it was in the 60s into july
into july that water was in the
60s do you have to cover a pool have you
read to do that it's disgusting it's
impossible do you ever have to uncover a
pool when summer hits it's terrible
there's mildew you have to drain the
pool and refill it you ask anybody do
you want a pool or not
they go
i want a pair you want to beat you're
not what are you talking about they
don't i'm talking you don't give earth
away joe okay do you want to pull or not
and by the way what you're going to have
to cut by the way by the way and by the
way
by the way and by the way when i say
private beach okay i know literally in
the sense that means private beach if
you go to beaches for instance around
the beaches around tampa florida they
are tiny little
uh uh oases okay there's like 10 people
on them okay there's like 10 people on
them
you're thinking you're applying every
beach to wildwood new jersey huge
boardwalk i started off talking about
tropical beaches and you shunned me for
it for being an elitist
the most beautiful beaches i've ever
been making a joke my point is i've been
in beautiful pools
beach beats a beautiful place my point
is all all public beaches are not
overcrowded with with there's plenty of
i get that there are plenty of public
beaches that would function as a private
beach i get the benefits of a beach i
love a great beach day i love a tropical
beach i get everything you're saying
which do i prefer if i had to choose one
i want the access
of a pool in my yard over being able to
drive down to the beach okay but if you
had the choice between a pool in your
yard or a private beach what should you
pick
you cannot compare those kids you can
yes well you can
yes you i will tell you
not worth millions of dollars you can
buy houses okay for under a million
dollars that have a little sliver of
private beach that leads out to a body
of water that is a fact so look up real
estate under a million dollars how much
is an above ground pool five thousand
dollars she'd rather you so you want an
above ground you're thinking above
ground but you're gonna give you all the
perks you're talking about right now not
a million dollar private beach that's
why you can't get a million dollar
private i'd rather be laying in a pool
than la in the sand on a beach that is
the argument here i understand going i'm
not going elsewhere i'm not going
elsewhere i'd rather
be in a pool on a float in a backyard
then baking under the sun around people
i don't know
the generals
so you'd rather have access to a fully
private pool is what you're saying yeah
but a private pool joe is
just
call it a private pool yes it is right
but i'd rather be in a yard in a pool
when i lived in l.a when i lived in
italy
when i lived when i lived in l.a when i
lived in l.a when i lived in la pete
homes and i talked about it all the time
we had we had spots we called secret
beach because there were so many places
you could go where there weren't tons of
people around you that's my point most
people saying most people are between
the goal posts buddy most people don't
have most people don't have access to a
nice little heated private pool
experience okay more people have access
to pool than beach yes or no
no
be out here i will this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp yep is there
anything interfering with your happiness
or preventing you from achieving your
goals me for me yeah christos stefano
that's true yes for me
clinical depression
but you can start communicating which is
which is chris's nickname
no but in all seriousness anxiety oh my
god yeah i mean we both have the dark
days both you know kidding aside guys
that kind of stuff escapes no one
especially after the couple years we're
coming out of and i really do say like
when we when we when we talk about stuff
i think better hub i'm hoping better
help reaches a lot of our listeners and
actually helps them they they assess
your needs they match you with a
professional licensed therapist uh you
can do it start it with under two days
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's just professional counseling and
it's done securely it's not self-help
either i think that's great that they
point that out yeah that they're
distinguishing you know this is
something to this is continuous
treatment for you yeah and and because
uh it's online it reaches clients
worldwide uh many uh who could be
experts in in things that aren't
available in in your area yeah uh we we
talk about it all the time um
but you just make an account you log on
you message your counselor and that's it
you are also running it's also
affordable more affordable than
traditional offline counseling financial
aid is also available
i mean guys start living happier today
this is so great what they're doing
they're making a service that is so
elusive to so many people so
all under one umbrella accessible
one-stop shop and accessible go to
betterhelp.com tastebuds that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com taste buds you're gonna join
over one million people who've taken
charge of their mental help go to
betterhelp.com
tastebuds today
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
taste buds
you're gonna join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional and our listeners uh get a
special offer 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
tastebuds
no you can drive i'm saying from where
you live like this coastal and then yeah
public pool absolutely but this coastal
and then it's in between the public
pools absolutely there's there's
probably x there's probably
i don't know 35 states that are
landlocked okay so those people have
pool experiences they don't have access
to they also have lakes that they go to
and swim in lakes are not part of this
neither are ponds why why can a lake
well lake has a beach what are you
talking about yes it is
why is that not a beach why is a lake
not a beach if there's sand and it meets
the water i'm talking i think
i took this as coastal that's how i took
it okay well that's not my fault okay
but still find actually the the lake and
the pond
disgusts me
i don't like a bay bather not really all
right again my point is
argue that a pond or a lake is better
i will take a beach at a lake
over a a pool yes i will no no no no no
see what you're doing now what you're
doing now is why we worded the the pole
the way we did we didn't say which is
better because it doesn't matter whether
a beautiful lake and a beautiful pool
the beautiful lakes better if you take a
beautiful beach
okay so that's that's that's what it's
not on a given day it's i am telling you
what i prefer okay
so you would eliminate pools from your
life as long as you had access to go to
a lake and drive there when you want
yeah you'd use a lake more than a
how many times do you think you you've
been in a pool or you will go in the
pool in a year in a year in a year do
you want me to say you want me to say do
you want me to say rental i will tell
you right now yeah when the two
vacations i've been on with you this
year as we said in the other episode it
sounds like all we do is take a vacation
i
fought tooth and nail every day to get
every question i asked you no that's my
question you're not giving me answer my
questions you order the code red
answer it how many times a year do you
go in the pool yeah i didn't go to the
beach by myself because none of my
friends wanted to question because none
of my friends were under my question
dude how many times a year do you go in
a pool on average 12 months out of the
year how many times this year
joe in general how many times would you
say you going to pool in a calendar year
i have no idea sir take a stab bro no
it's a podcast
all right because you know it's
probably a couple dozen at least right
it's not a couple days i've been with
you in a pool a couple dozen times this
year because because you refused to go
to the beach with me i would ask
refused to go to the beach and i had to
stay in the pool because none of my
friends would go to the beach what does
that have to do with this you're right i
chose to be social with my friends
instead of going alone to a beach you
are like a child i'm not a child that is
that doesn't know like that you you're
not focusing on now you're not making a
fair argument i'm asking you on a
general year how many times do you go in
a pool and how many times do you go to
beach lake i don't know okay so you
don't even want to answer that question
then don't no okay i'm basically in
court you'd look bad right now i'm
basing it on the last two years and i'm
telling you something and do not dismiss
this the last two times we went away i
said i want to go to the beach and you
refuse to go does that happen i would
have went every day if any of my [ __ ]
lazy
yeah and my point is you don't even go
someone can't go with you you don't have
access to the goal beaches are free
alone at the beach but you don't have
access i'm not going to go alone and sit
down i had fun
how many times do you go in a pool and
how many times do you go to a blake
before this year okay in our two
vacations i can't even tell you the last
time i was in a pool i never saw
somebody like the pool as much as you
did that's fine answer the question no
matter what the zero is zero so you you
average zero times in a pool a year
average going to a lake
only two
uh four or five got it so on your
average year joe derosa you go to the
beach at the lake five times periods
period beach period well you i'm wow
cause that is what i'm directly asking
you this over that section but you you
had a coronary
you said i prefer a a beach at a lake
over a pool and then my next question
was trying to be for last time saying so
i've been to beach lakes you would drive
i wonder if you drive the listeners man
because they can't even
you won't answer a simple question one
so one versus zero pool five beaches
when i go when i go to parties 90 of the
time unless it's with you i do not go in
the pool i don't care to go in the pool
i don't give a [ __ ] about the pool okay
when i go to a beach i get excited i
want to go in the ocean i like going in
the ocean that's great i understand that
you prefer pools i mean peaches i get it
that's not my question well that's what
the argument is no i'm trying to prove a
point you won't let me get there sally
have three minutes until 8 30.
all right let's go to the polls
unless we pause and i do 10 minutes we
come back
now let's just go to the
salvage kid today pal i'm exhausted but
joe you you
why wouldn't you answer a simple
question because you don't want to go
down that road because i have a great
balance it's a question
it's an idiotic most people's experience
is they get a chance to go in a pool
more times and they get a chance to go
to a beach or especially a lake beach
which was the heels of what i was
talking about so i think that most
people would say well you know i should
get more use out of pools no matter what
even if i don't oh i mean i'm trying to
make a simple point but i'm talk i'm
speaking to how i think which do you
prefer
not which do you go in more often not
which is the better show
i prefer a lake beach i prefer a lake
well you're not listening i'm trying to
apply it to how i think the poll is
going to result and i'm speaking to how
i think people interpret their
experiences and i think you're going to
lose because i think that more people
will say well geez i get to go to the
beach twice a year but i get to go into
place 15 20 times so i'll take i prefer
pool clock stick okay let's see what it
is then you
do you want to keep you're insane
you have gone inside you're the one with
the you've gone insane you're the one
with the deadline you have gone insane
you are irrational i'm not irrational
you won't even let me make a simple
point you've made your point i don't
agree that i think it's a stupid point
you're applying logic and you're just
you're not going logical you're not
applying well i think you're making a
bad point if i lose in this one you're
gonna lose
thank you mother
i don't even need to do my plugs i still
love you
you're gonna let me say i love you too
are you gonna yes
that's my favorite win of all time
you're gonna let me say i love you too
or no
well i don't
wow
taste bugs they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking